Some of you have heard the story before,
but, in fact, there's somebody
in the audience
who's never heard this story
in front of an audience before,
so I'm a little more nervous
than I normally am telling this story.
I used to be a photographer
for many years.
In 1978, I was working for "TIME Magazine"
and I was given a three-day assignment
to photograph Amerasian children,
children who had been fathered
by American GIs all over Southeast Asia,
and then abandoned --
40,000 children all over Asia.
I had never heard
the word Amerasian before.
I spent a few days photographing
children in different countries,
and like a lot of photographers
and a lot of journalists,
I always hoped that
when my pictures are published,
they might actually
have an effect on a situation,
instead of just documenting it.
So, I was so disturbed by what I saw
and I was so unhappy
with the article that ran afterwards,
that I decided
I would take six months off.
I was 28 years old.
I decided I would find
six children in different countries,
and actually go spend
some time with the kids,
and try to tell their story
a little bit better
than I thought I had done
for Time magazine.
In the course of doing the story,
I was looking for children
who hadn't been photographed before,
and the Pearl Buck Foundation told me
that they worked with a lot of Americans
who were donating money
to help some of these kids.
And a man told me,
who ran the Pearl Buck
Foundation in Korea,
that there was a young girl,
who was 11 years old,
being raised by her grandmother.
And the grandmother
had never let any Westerners see her.
Every time any Westerners
came to the village, she hid the girl.
Of course, I was immediately intrigued.
I saw photographs of her
and I thought I wanted to go.
And the guy just told me,
"This grandmother -- there's no way
she's ever going to let you
meet this girl that's she's raising."
I took a translator with me
and went to this village,
found the grandmother, sat down with her.
And to my astonishment, she agreed
to let me photograph her granddaughter.
And I was paying for this myself,
so I asked the translator
if it would be OK
if I stayed for the week.
I had a sleeping bag.
The family had a small shed
on the side of the house,
so I said, "Could I sleep
in my sleeping bag in the evenings?"
And I just told the little girl,
whose name was Eun-Sook Lee,
that if I ever did anything
to embarrass her --
she didn't speak a word of English,
although she looked very American --
she could put up her hand and say, "Stop,"
and I would stop taking pictures.
Then my translator left.
I couldn't speak a word of Korean.
This is the first night I met Eun-Sook.
Her mother was still alive.
She was not raising her,
her grandmother was raising her.
And what struck me immediately
was how in love
the two of these people were.
The grandmother was incredibly fond,
deeply in love with this little girl.
They slept on the floor at night.
The way they heat their homes in Korea
is to put bricks under the floors,
so the heat radiates
from underneath the floor.
Eun-Sook was 11 years old.
I had photographed,
as I said, a lot of these kids.
Eun-Sook was the fifth child
that I found to photograph.
And almost universally,
amongst all the kids,
they were really psychologically damaged
by having been made fun of,
ridiculed, picked on and been rejected.
And Korea was probably the place
I found to be the worst for these kids.
And what struck me immediately
in meeting Eun-Sook
was how confident she appeared to be,
how happy she seemed to be
in her own skin.
And remember this picture,
because I'm going to show you
another picture later.
She looks much like her grandmother,
although she looks so Western.
I decided to follow her to school.
This is the first morning
I stayed with her.
This is on the way to school.
This is the morning assembly
outside her school.
And I noticed that
she was clowning around.
When the teachers would ask questions,
she'd be the first person
to raise her hand.
Again, not at all shy or withdrawn,
or anything like the other children
that I'd photographed.
The first one to go
to the blackboard to answer questions.
Getting in trouble for whispering
into her best friend's ears.
And one of the other things
I said to her through the translator --
again, this thing about saying stop --
was to not pay attention to me.
So she really just completely
ignored me most of the time.
I noticed that at recess,
she was the girl who picked
the other girls to be on her team.
It was very obvious, from the beginning,
that she was a leader.
This is on the way home.
And that's North Korea up along the hill.
This is up along the DMZ.
They would actually
cover the windows every night,
so that light couldn't be seen,
because the South Korean government
has said for years
that the North Koreans
may invade at any time.
So the closer you were to North Korea,
the more terrifying it was.
Very often at school,
I'd be taking pictures,
and she would whisper
into her girlfriends' ears,
and then look at me and say, "Stop."
And I would stand at attention,
and all the girls would crack up,
and it was sort of a little joke.
(Laughter)
The end of the week came
and my translator came back,
because I'd asked her to come back,
so I could formally thank
the grandmother and Eun-Sook.
And in the course of the grandmother
talking to the translator,
the grandmother started crying.
And I said to my translator,
"What's going on, why is she crying?"
And she spoke to
the grandmother for a moment,
and then she started
getting tears in her eyes.
And I said, "What did I do?
Why is everyone crying?"
And the translator said,
"The grandmother says
that she thinks she's dying,
and she wants to know if you would take
Eun-Sook to America with you."
And I said, "I'm 28 years old
and I live in hotels,
and I'm not married."
I mean, I had fallen in love
with this girl,
but you know, emotionally
I was about 12 years old.
If you know of photographers,
the joke is it's the finest form
of delayed adolescence ever invented.
"Sorry, I have to go
on an assignment, I'll be back" --
and then you never come back.
So I asked the translator
why she thought she was dying.
Can I get her to a hospital?
Could I pay to get her a doctor?
And she refused any help at all.
So when I got outside,
I gave the translator some money and said,
"Go back and see if you can do something."
And I gave the grandmother
my business card.
And I said, "If you're serious,
I will try to find a family for her."
And I immediately wrote a letter
to my best friends in Atlanta, Georgia,
who had an 11-year-old son.
And my best friend
had mistakenly one day said something
about wishing he had another child.
So my friends Gene and Gayle
had not heard from me in about a year,
and suddenly I was calling,
saying "I'm in Korea
and I've met this extraordinary girl."
And I said, "The grandmother
thinks she's sick,
but I think maybe we would have to
bring the grandmother over also."
And I said, "I'll pay for the ... "
I mean, I had this whole sort of picture.
So anyway, I left.
And my friends actually said
they were very interested in adopting her.
And I said, "Look, I think
I'll scare the grandmother to death,
if I tell her that
you're willing to adopt her.
I want to go back and talk to her."
But I was off on assignment.
I figured I'd come back
in a couple of weeks
and talk to the grandmother.
And on Christmas Day, I was in Bangkok
with a group of photographers
and got a telegram --
back in those days, you got telegrams --
from Time magazine
saying someone in Korea had died
and left their child in a will to me.
Did I know anything about this?
Because I hadn't told them
what I was doing,
because I was so upset
with the story they'd run.
So, I went back to Korea,
and I went back to Eun-Sook's village,
and she was gone.
And the house that
I had spent time in was empty.
It was incredibly cold.
No one in the village
would tell me where Eun-Sook was,
because the grandmother
had always hidden her from Westerners.
And they had no idea
about this request that she'd made of me.
So I finally found Myung Sung,
her best friend that she used to play with
after school every day.
And Myung Sung, under some pressure
from me and the translator,
gave us an address
on the outside of Seoul.
And I went to that address
and knocked on the door,
and a man answered the door.
It was not a very nice area of Seoul,
there were mud streets outside of it.
And I knocked on the door
and Eun-Sook answered the door,
and her eyes were bloodshot,
and she seemed to be in shock.
She didn't recognize me --
there was no recognition whatsoever.
And this man came to the door
and kind of barked something in Korean.
And I said to the translator,
"What did he say?"
And she said, "He wants
to know who you are."
And I said, "Tell him
that I am a photographer."
I started explaining who I was,
and he interrupted.
And she said, "He says he knows
who you are, what do you want?"
I said, "Well, tell him that I was asked
by this little girl's grandmother
to find a family for her."
And he said, "I'm her uncle,
she's fine, you can leave now."
So I was --
The door was being slammed in my face,
it's incredibly cold,
and I'm trying to think,
"What would the hero do in a movie,
if I was writing this as a movie script?"
So I said, "It's really cold,
I've come a very long way,
do you mind if I come in
for a minute? I'm freezing."
So the guy reluctantly let us in
and we sat down on the floor.
And as we started talking,
I saw him yell something,
and Eun-Sook came
and brought us some food.
And I had this whole mental picture
of -- sort of like Cinderella.
I sort of had this picture
of this incredibly wonderful,
bright, happy little child,
who now appeared to be very withdrawn,
being enslaved by this family.
And I was really appalled,
and I couldn't figure out what to do.
And the more I tried talking to him,
the less friendly he was getting.
So finally I said "Look," --
this is all through the translator,
because, you know,
I don't speak a word of Korean --
and I said, "Look, I'm really glad
that Eun-Sook has a family to live with.
I was very worried about her.
I made a promise to her grandmother,
your mother, that I would find a family,
and I'm so happy that
you're going to take care of her.
But I bought an airline ticket
and I'm stuck here for a week.
I'm staying in a hotel downtown.
Would you like to come
and have lunch tomorrow?
And you can practice your English."
Because he told me -- I was trying
to ask him questions about himself.
And so I went to the hotel,
and I found two older Amerasians.
A girl whose mother had been a prostitute,
and she was a prostitute,
and a boy who'd been in and out of jail.
And I said to them,
"Look, there's a little girl
who has a tiny chance
of getting out of here
and going to America.
I don't know if it's
the right decision or not,
but I would like you
to come to lunch tomorrow
and tell the uncle what it's like
to walk down the street,
what people say to you,
what you do for a living.
I want him to understand
what happens if she stays here.
And I could be wrong, I don't know,
but I wish you would come tomorrow."
So, these two came to lunch
and we got thrown out of the restaurant.
They were yelling at him,
it got to be really ugly.
We went outside, and he was just furious.
And I knew I had totally blown this thing.
Here I was again,
trying to figure out what to do.
And he started yelling at me,
and I said to the translator,
"Tell him to calm down,
what is he saying?"
And she said, "He's saying, 'Who the hell
are you to walk into my house,
some rich American
with your cameras around your neck,
accusing me of enslaving my niece?
This is my niece, I love her,
she's my sister's daughter.
Who the hell are you
to accuse me of something like this?'"
And I said, you know,
"Look, you're absolutely right.
I don't pretend to understand
what's going on here.
All I know is, I've been
photographing a lot of these children.
I'm in love with your niece,
I think she's an incredibly
special child."
And I said, "Look, I will fly my friends
over here from the United States
if you want to meet them,
to see if you approve of them.
I just think that --
what little I know about the situation,
she has very little chance here
of having the kind of life
that you probably would like her to have."
So, everyone told me afterwards
that inviting the prospective parents over
was, again, the stupidest thing
I could have possibly done,
because who's ever
good enough for your relative?
But he invited me to come to a ceremony
they were having that day
for her grandmother.
And they actually take
items of clothing and photographs,
and they burn them as part of the ritual.
And you can see how different she looks
just in three months.
This was now, I think, early February.
And the pictures before
were taken in September.
Well, there was
an American Maryknoll priest
that I had met in the course
of doing the story,
who had 75 children living in his house.
He had three women helping him
take care of these kids.
And so I suggested to the uncle
that we go down and meet Father Keane
to find out how
the adoption process worked.
Because I wanted him to feel
like this was all being done
very much above board.
So, this is on the way
down to the orphanage.
This is Father Keane.
He's just a wonderful guy.
He had kids from
all over Korea living there,
and he would find families for these kids.
This is a social worker
interviewing Eun-Sook.
Now, I had always thought she was
completely untouched by all of this,
because the grandmother, to me,
appeared to be sort of
the village wise woman --
throughout the day, I noticed people
kept coming to visit her grandmother.
And I always had this mental picture
that even though they may have been
one of the poorer families in the village,
they were one of the most respected.
And I always felt that the grandmother
had kind of demanded, and insisted,
that the villagers treat Eun-Sook
with the same respect they treated her.
Eun-Sook stayed at Father Keane's,
and her uncle agreed to let her stay there
until the adoption went through.
He actually agreed to the adoption.
And I went off on assignment
and came back a week later,
and Father Keane said,
"I've got to talk to you about Eun-Sook."
I said, "Oh God, now what?"
And he takes me into this room,
closes the door and says,
"I have 75 children here in the orphanage,
and it's total bedlam."
There's clothes, there's kids.
Three adults and 75 kids --
you can imagine.
And he said, "The second day
she was here she made up a list
of all of the names
of the older kids and the younger kids.
And she assigned one of the older kids
to each of the younger kids.
And then she set up a work detail list
of who cleaned the orphanage on what day."
And he said, "She's telling me
that I'm messy
and I have to clean up my room."
And he said, "I don't know who raised her,
but she's running the orphanage,
and she's been here three days."
(Laughter)
This was movie day that she organized
where all the kids went to the movies.
A lot of the kids who had been adopted
wrote back to the other kids,
telling them what their life
was like with their new families.
So it was a really big deal
when the letters showed up.
This is a woman who is
now working at the orphanage,
whose son had been adopted.
Gene and Gayle started studying Korean
the moment they had gotten
my first letter.
They really wanted to be able
to welcome Eun-Sook into their family.
And one of the things Father Keane told me
when I came back
from one of these trips --
Eun-Sook had chosen the name Natasha,
which I understood was from her watching
a "Rocky and Bullwinkle" cartoon
on the American Air Force station.
This may be one
of those myth-buster things
that we'll have to
clear up here, in a minute.
So, my friend Gene
flew over with his son, Tim.
Gayle couldn't come.
And they spent a lot of time
huddled over a dictionary.
And this was Gene showing the uncle
where Atlanta was on the map,
where he lived.
This is the uncle
signing the adoption papers.
Now, we went out to dinner
that night to celebrate.
The uncle went back to his family
and Natasha and Tim and Gene and I
went out to dinner.
And Gene was showing Natasha
how to use a knife and fork,
and then Natasha
was returning the utensil lessons.
We went back to our hotel room,
and Gene was showing Natasha
also where Atlanta was.
This is the third night we were in Korea.
The first night we'd gotten a room
for the kids right next to us.
I'd been staying in this room
for about three months --
it was a little 15-story Korean hotel.
The second night,
we didn't keep the kids' room,
because we slept on the floor
with all the kids at the orphanage.
And the third night, we came back --
we'd just gone out to dinner,
where you saw the pictures --
and we got to the front desk,
and the guy said,
"There's no other free rooms
on your floor tonight,
you can put the kids
five floors below you."
And Gene and I
looked at each other and said,
"We don't want two 11-year-olds
five floors away."
So his son said, "I have a sleeping bag,
I'll sleep on the floor."
And I said, "I have one too."
So Tim and I slept on the floor,
Natasha got one bed,
Gene got the other -- kids pass out,
it's been very exciting for three days.
We're lying in bed, and Gene and I
are talking about how cool we are.
We said, "That was so great,
we saved this little girl's life."
We were just like,
you know, just full of ourselves.
And we fall asleep --
and I've been in this room
for a couple of months now.
And they always overheat
the hotels in Korea terribly,
so during the day
I always left the window open.
And then about midnight,
they turn the heat off in the hotel.
So at 1am, the whole room would be
like 20 below zero, and I'd get up.
I'd been doing this
every night I'd been there.
So, sure enough,
it's one o'clock, room's freezing,
I go to close the window
and I hear people shouting outside,
and I thought, "Oh, the bars
must have just gotten out."
I don't speak Korean,
but I'm hearing these voices,
and I'm not hearing anger,
I'm hearing terror.
So I open the window and I look out,
and there's flames
coming up the side of our hotel,
and the hotel's on fire.
So I run over to Gene and I wake him up,
and I say, "Don't freak out,
I think the hotel's on fire."
And now there's smoke and flames
coming by our windows --
we're on the 11th floor.
So the two of us were just like,
"Oh my God, oh my God."
So we're trying to get Natasha up,
and we can't talk to her.
You know what kids are like
when they've been asleep for like an hour,
it's like they took five Valiums --
they're all over the place.
And we can't talk to her.
His son had the L.L.Bean bootlaces,
and we're trying to do up his laces.
So we try to get to the door,
we run to the door, we open the door,
and it's like walking
into a blast furnace.
There's people screaming,
the sound of glass breaking, weird thumps.
And the whole room filled
with smoke in about two seconds.
And Gene turns around and says,
"We're not going to make it."
And he closes the door, and the whole room
is now filled with smoke.
We're all choking, and there's smoke
pouring through the vents,
under the doors.
There's people screaming.
I just remember this unbelievable --
just utter chaos.
I remember sitting near the bed,
and I had two overwhelming feelings.
One was absolute terror.
"Oh, please God, I just want to wake up.
This has got to be a nightmare,
this can't be happening.
Please, I just want to wake up."
And the other is unbelievable guilt.
Here I've been playing God
with my friends' lives,
my friends' son, with Natasha's life,
and this what you get when you try
playing God, is you hurt people.
I remember just being
so frightened and terrified.
And Gene, who's lying on the floor, says,
"We've got to soak towels."
I said, "What?"
"We've got to soak towels.
We're going to die from the smoke."
So got towels and put them
over our faces and the kids' faces.
Then he said, "Do you have gaffer's tape?"
"What?" "Do you have gaffer's tape?"
I said, "Somewhere in my Halliburton."
He says, "We've got to stop the smoke.
That's all we can do."
I mean, Gene -- thank God for Gene.
So we put the room service menus
over the vents in the wall,
we put blankets at the bottom of the door,
we put the kids on the windowsill
to try to get some air.
And there was a new building, going up,
that was being built
right across the street from our hotel.
And there, in the building,
were photographers,
waiting for people to jump.
Eleven people ended up dying in the fire.
Five people jumped and died,
other people were killed by the smoke.
And there's this loud thumping on the door
after about 45 minutes in all this,
and people were shouting in Korean.
And I remember --
Natasha didn't want us opening the door --
sorry, I was trying not to open the door,
because we'd spent so much time
barricading the room.
I didn't know who it was,
I didn't know what they wanted,
and Natasha could tell
they were firemen trying to get us out.
I remember a sort of a tussle at the door,
trying to get the door open.
In any case, 12 hours later --
I mean, they put us in the lobby.
Gene ended up using his coat,
and his fist in the coat,
to break open a liquor cabinet.
People were lying on the floor.
It was one of just
the most horrifying nights.
And then 12 hours later,
we rented a car, as we had planned to,
and drove back to Natasha's village.
And we kept saying, "Do you realize
we were dying in a hotel fire,
like eight hours ago?"
It's so weird how life just goes on.
Natasha wanted to introduce her brother
and father to all the villagers,
and the day we showed up turned out
to be a 60-year-old man's birthday.
This guy's 60 years old.
So it turned into a dual celebration,
because Natasha was
the first person from this village
ever to go to the United States.
So, these are the greenhouse tents.
This is the elders
teaching Gene their dances.
We drank a lot of rice wine.
We were both so drunk,
I couldn't believe it.
This is the last picture
before Gene and Tim headed back.
The adoption people told us
it was going to take a year
for the adoption to go through.
Like, what could you do for a year?
So I found out the name of every official
on both the Korean and American side,
and I photographed them,
and told them how famous they were
going to be when this book was done.
And four months later,
the adoption papers came through.
This is saying goodbye
to everybody at the orphanage.
This is Father Keane with Natasha
at the bus stop.
Her great aunt at the airport.
I had a wonderful deal with Cathay Pacific
airlines for many years,
where they gave me free passes
on all their airlines
in return for photography.
It was like the ultimate perk.
And the pilot, I actually knew --
because they used to let me sit
in the jump seat,
to tell you how long ago this was.
This is a TriStar, and so they let Natasha
actually sit in the jump seat.
And the pilot, Jeff Cowley,
actually went back
and adopted one of the other kids
at the orphanage after meeting Natasha.
This is 28 hours later in Atlanta.
It's a very long flight.
Just to make things even crazier,
Gayle, Natasha's new mom,
was three days away
from giving birth to her own daughter.
You know, if you were
writing this, you'd say,
"No, we've got to write
the script differently."
This is the first night showing Natasha
her new cousins and uncles and aunts.
Gene and Gayle know everyone in Atlanta --
they're the most social couple imaginable.
So, at this point, Natasha
doesn't speak a word of English,
other than what little
Father Keane taught her.
This is Kylie, her sister,
who's now a doctor, on the right.
This is a deal I had with Natasha,
which is that when we got to Atlanta
she could cut off my beard.
She never liked it very much.
She learned English in three months.
She entered seventh grade
at her own age level.
Pledge of Allegiance for the first time.
This is her cooking teacher.
Natasha told me a lot of the kids
thought she was stuck up,
because they would talk to her
and she wouldn't answer,
and they didn't realize
she didn't speak English very well.
But what I noticed, again as an observer,
was she was choosing
who was going to be on her team,
and seemed to be very popular
very, very quickly.
Now, remember the picture,
how much she looked like
her grandmother, at the beginning?
People were always telling Natasha
how much she looks like her mother, Gayle.
(Laughter)
This is a tense moment
in the first football game, I think.
And Kylie -- I mean, it was
almost like Kylie was her own child.
She's being baptized.
Now, a lot of parents, when they adopt,
actually want to erase
their children's history.
And Gayle and Gene
did the complete opposite.
They were studying Korean;
they bought Korean clothes.
Gene even did a little
tile work in the kitchen,
which was that, "Once upon a time,
there was a beautiful girl
that came from the hills of Korea
to live happily ever after in Atlanta."
She hates this picture --
it was her first job.
She bought a bright red Karmann Ghia
with the money she made
working at Burger King.
The captain of the cheerleaders.
Beauty pageant.
Used to do their
Christmas card every year.
Gene's been restoring this car
for a million years.
Kodak hired Natasha to be a translator
for them at the Olympics in Korea.
Her future husband, Jeff,
was working for Canon cameras,
and met Natasha at the Olympic Village.
This is her first trip back to Korea.
So there's her uncle.
This is her half sister.
She went back to the village.
That's her best friend's mother.
And I always thought that was
a very Annie Hall kind of outfit.
(Laughter)
It's just, you know, it was
just so interesting, just to watch --
this is her mother
in the background there.
This is Natasha's wedding day.
Gene is looking a little older.
This is Sydney, who's going to be
three years old in a couple of days.
And there's Evan.
And Natasha, would you
just come up, for a second,
just maybe to say hello to everybody?
(Applause)
Natasha's actually
never heard me tell the story.
You know, we've looked
at the pictures together.
Natasha: I've seen pictures
millions of times,
but today was the first time I'm actually
seeing him give the whole presentation.
I started crying.
Rick Smolan: There's about 40 things
she's going to tell me,
"That wasn't what happened."
Natasha: I'll tell you that later.
RS: Anyway, thank you, Mike and Richard,
so much for letting us tell the story.
Thank you, all of you.
(Applause)